[Music]
well good evening what would a Tucker
Carlson tonight you may think the media
are capable only of skepticism and
loathing but think again journalists can
love to their latest crush the
Democratic People's Republic of North
Korea kim yo-jong whose brother is of
course the undisputed dictator of that
Stalinist hermit Kingdom is at the
Winter Olympics this weekend according
to the press she's a huge star bigger
star even than our vice president Mike
Pence or for that matter a bigger star
than any of the actual athletes don't
believe it consider some of these
descriptions from the Washington Post
quote the Ivanka Trump of North Korea
captivates from CNN she's stealing the
show the New York Times says she turns
on the charm Reuters the news wire
meanwhile writes this quote North Korea
has emerged as the early favorite to
grab one of the Winter Olympics --iz
most important medals the diplomatic
Gold
Law or reporters gushed over the world's
last totality reinstate Mike Pence who
again is the vice president United
States was attacked for not standing up
to honor North Korean athletes watch
this was it Mike Pence said that it was
inappropriate to make political
statements at sporting events if you're
in Korea you need to stand up you need
to stand up and show respect the
Olympics are supposed to be the one
place where politics is not supposed to
play a part
well if you're surprised you shouldn't
be progressives have a long and
dishonorable history of supporting the
world's most repressive regimes no
exaggeration the New York Times just
name one example supported Joseph Stalin
even as he was murdering up to 12
million Ukrainians in the famous famine
there that paper also led the cheering
for Fidel Castro as he turned Cuba into
a police state in 1975 and we're not
making this up when the camera Rouge
swept to power in Cambodia the Khmer
Rouge the New York Times made this
prediction in a headline quote for most
a better life one of the worst genocides
in history followed shortly thereafter
not to be true well it's hard to find a
dictator the left has not supported
Chairman Mao Hugo Chavez Idi Amin these
people seem to have nothing in common
but one thing they all hate America
turns out progressive activists also
have one thing in common they resent
their fathers that's where their
politics come from the rest is just
window dressing dear Joe Griswold is
editor of workers world it's a weekly
communist newspaper that supports the
North Korean regime or she has visited
and she joins us tonight dear thanks
coming on so um you you're a longtime
communist you're a longtime supporter of
the DPRK you visited at the invitation
of the government you think its leaders
are great when you see CNN and Reuters
agreeing with you that its leaders are
great that that must validate you I mean
you must cheer as you watch the Olympic
coverage I've been to both North Korea
and South Korea mhm and I'm on this
program because I want to talk to the
people who watch your show and make a
serious point yeah we're in the process
of moving towards a nuclear war and they
they have never experienced that but the
Korean people know very much what war is
like and they're not for it and the
people of South Korea don't want war any
more than the people of North Korea do
and they showed that at the Olympics
when the Europe in the opening
ceremonies when they cheered with great
joy the fact that the North and the
South were marching together so it since
you've been to both countries I'm just
wondering so one is obviously the
world's last Stalinist regime it's
pretty rigidly Marxist
North Korea South Korea is floridly
capitalist it's a market-based economy
which of course you reject which country
would you rather live in personally I
won't try to answer and debate you and
everything you've said minutes by what I
want to talk about is what I think is
really important to the people of this
country that is that there's a group in
Washington that really wants to push for
a war the Korean people don't want it
people here don't want a war but they
don't know what a war is like they think
you just push a button somewhere we just
say that I've never said this to a
communist before but I actually agree
with you I don't want a war in Korea and
I think there are people in Washington
or pushing for it I think you're
absolutely right there I guess where I
disagree with you is we don't know what
the people of North Korea want because
they're not allowed to say what they
want
really so I do they have internet access
there oh they don't
okay what's going on how would they know
because it's illegal to watch a foreign
movie there's a lot of stuff North Korea
are very aware of what's going on in the
world
North Korea has a 100% literacy rate did
you know that I do yeah I got that
figure from the CIA fact oh why you see
they're just well but if you can't read
anything they're not in some kind of you
know jail they're not they are really
they are people who want to get out from
underneath the threat of war that the US
has posed ever since it in there okay I
know you don't want to debate by what
you mean you don't want to answer real
questions but let's just try a couple of
them if they're free why can't they
leave look what's a fair question
shocking for them people go back and
forth you know you you're taking you
this whole it in a whole other direction
that shouldn't be of any significance to
people here was
because your air up here speaking
Washington who are for a war what that's
one of the questions I've never been
able to answer in 35 years here but I I
one question I've been able to answer
pretty simply is this North Korea a free
place a place you'd want to live or is
it a prison do you know what the
imprisonment rate of North Korea is it's
800 per hundred thousand you know what
it is it says in the United States I'm
sorry you prison rate this very hard
u.s. has nowhere near any other country
in the world that's not true actually
North Korea has no no that's not true
North Korea is the highest but let me
stress you guys sure no I'm talking
about the number of prisoners that's the
highest in the world in the United
States that's why that's true and would
you say the United States the majority
of more poor people and they wouldn't be
in jail if they had a lawyer to keep
them out of jail right actually this is
kind of the point I was making is that
no regime no matter how repressive no
matter how many its own people it has
killed is ever undefended by the left if
it's hates America if North Korea
suddenly became pro-american you
wouldn't support it would you you know
that you wouldn't you say that the this
is a country that hates America no I
would say that of North Korea I think
that's fair to say having to this
country and bomb us did they ever do
what the US did to Korea should you
really feel good about what the US did
to Korea the u.s. bombed every building
over one story should you think real or
right so do MERS have to come back with
a their payloads I'm drop because I
wonder why do you think you dislike them
do you ever just a quick reality check
do you ever say to yourself you know I
dislike America where I live I don't
know what I dislike North Korea like the
people in this country at all I'm with
you there with you there who are
actually doing the planning for let me
ask you one last question
do this games coming up against me yeah
works but I just want to ask you one
last question it's cr1 I got it
does it bother you at all does it make
you rethink your defense of North Korea
when you see its population starving and
its leader dying of obesity some years
ago you know this is a country that was
left in ashes into ashes just a
generation a half ago
thanks okay what are you three get so
built up they rebuilt their country they
have you know they if you look at the
careers they're the healthiest looking
people except for the tapeworms people
lies about the world and that's what
your station does and now we're not
surprised by that well we're glad to
have you on for some truth character
thank you so much